This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Right here we are.
It's time for your mom's house podcast.
You get it.
Um,
and Christina does it works.
Here we go,
Jean.
Oh,
oh my gosh.
Listen,
uh,
this is a very unusual podcast.
We are dealing too hectic day.
I am on the verge of tears.
Um,
I sang,
I don't know why I'm getting emotional,
but our neighborhood is burning down around us and we're kind of doing this
before we have to go.
Um,
I just want to apologize to everybody in West Silver Springs,
Oklahoma,
the Cherokee casino.
I was supposed to fly there tonight and I could not get on a plane and leave my
babies and my home.
Um,
right now cause we are going to be leaving pretty soon to evacuate.
So yeah,
sorry guys.
But hopefully this will be over quickly and we can resume our normal lives.
So,
uh,
November 14th,
Pasadena,
I'm doing the ice house in the small room.
November 18th.
Flappers same thing.
Small Room,
November 24th,
San Diego,
California,
House of Blues,
late show tickets available.
Uh,
December 1st again back at flappers and the in the you who December 7th filler
up Delphia late show.
Uh,
there's still some tickets available.
And then December 8th,
Gramercy theater,
like literally just a very few tickets.
Your ride or die tour continues through January,
January 10th,
Hollywood at the comedy store.
And then I go to Denver comedy works,
Madison,
Wisconsin,
Comedy Club on State Mini Apple tits at acme and Tempe Improv and then the DCM.
Pravin June.
So tickets at Christina p online again.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm so sad.
You know,
you don't have to be sorry.
Well,
I,
you know,
I've never canceled a show in 15 years.
I'm like you said,
I got on the plane,
I booked a yacht and I went on a vacation.
There's a natural disaster.
I know,
but I,
you know,
I get on those planes no matter what.
I've had a fever,
I've held cancel.
I never,
never,
never.
And um,
I just hate it.
I hate what's happening right here is kind of different.
Yeah,
it's like the worst fire we've ever had here.
Yeah.
It's very,
I,
you know,
we'll go,
we'll talk it out.
We'll get into and then,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
but anyways,
don't,
don't be sad.
Wow.
I can't help it.
It's feelings.
Tom.
I don't have emotions.
Anyways.
Um,
let's see.
It's an exciting week for me.
Um,
natural disasters aside because,
uh,
I'm going this week to Montclair,
New Jersey.
The welmont both shows are sold out.
I'm doing four shows at the Miriam and Philadelphia.
Uh,
the only show with tickets left and it now it's even more limited is the late
show.
Friday,
November 16th,
that's exciting.
But also November 16th,
instant family,
that movie that I shot earlier this year,
I was gone for awhile.
Um,
it's really a great movie.
It's a family movie.
It's not in the theme of your mom's house.
It's not an r rated comedy,
but it is a great film.
Sean Andrews directed it.
Stars Mark Walberg and Rose Byrne and a,
yours truly has a fun Hartnett.
Uh,
I've seen it.
I'm going to go see it again.
Um,
even pay attention,
by the way to my Instagram,
I might even do a screening at a theater sometime in the next few weeks.
And,
uh,
I will invite people,
so pay attention to that.
That'll be here in the Los Angeles area,
maybe out in the VI.
Yay.
Um,
but anyways,
I appreciate all your support.
Anybody that goes in seasons,
that family,
it,
uh,
it's,
it's very beneficial to me and to the people who made this great movie.
Um,
the tourist stuff,
Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
You guys know that a,
that tour has been growing and growing and we just added a second show in
Cincinnati hometown coming through for me.
We had this check at the second show at the Aronoff.
Uh,
I think it's center for the arts.
That's February 15th,
that week.
I'm also doing two in Pittsburgh too,
in Cleveland and two in d c uh,
you know where to go for those tickets.
square.com/tony or it's very exciting stuff.
So the Trans Canada highway,
no,
that's uh,
that's the jest glass and guide.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It kind of moves kind of most,
you know,
we are going to have to tell them about the way you said free there.
I think we might have to start doing that all the time.
Was something,
did I do it?
You said is right.
Free postage.
I've never heard that.
I could see that being a national jingle
boasted whoa.
No,
I'm feeling very well.
I'm feeling freer than feel an existential today.
Okay.
Who knows what's going to happen.
Our lives are not in our control.
It's been a wild ride.
We'll talk.
Let's talk about it.
Let's open the show properly.
Yeah.
Real proper.
Like,
hi.
Hi.
Really got boat.
I think they greasy,
but they not.
Is that what he says?
Yeah.
That's Kinda how greasy,
but they know something's there.
I don't say that.
That's not my thing to say that one.
Okay.
All right,
let's do it.
Let's do it.
Let's do
it.
Oh Shit.
Oh boy.
Here we go.
Crazy tree.
No,
no,
no.
Don't bring it in.
Loving.
Well,
go to your mom's house.
Do you want to tell the audience that we had sex the other day?
Did we?
Oh,
oh,
oh.
Is that audio from our,
Anna's asking my way is all this chaos by the way,
started on our anniversary.
And can I tell you we've had the worst anniversary luck.
So two anniversaries ago,
we woke up to find that Donald Trump was our leader.
That was to you two anniversaries.
You got it.
Yeah.
Now this one,
we wake up to the world is on fire.
It was fucked up.
We had a very special,
okay,
so I plan this,
uh,
it was like,
oh,
we're going to do some real switch.
Our 10 year anniversary,
do something really special.
So I plan just one night because we have babies.
You know,
we have young,
young kid.
He can't be away for long.
No,
I played one night,
very special place.
I'm always going to be great evenings,
just you and I.
And we went up to napa to a wine country,
to nappy headed,
uh,
wine country.
And while we're up there,
it's like we check in.
I'm like,
what is that?
And they're like,
that's ash.
I'm like,
Ash.
You're like,
yeah,
there's a big fire up in Butte county.
Okay,
okay.
Bud County,
California.
So we had a,
okay.
We're like,
is that a threat here?
Like not really.
It's 200 miles from here.
They tell you sooner,
miles.
Then all of a sudden later,
they're like,
hey,
that fire is spreading a 800 800 yards a minute.
It's growing.
I was like,
that's pretty fast.
800 yards a minute.
So anyway,
as that's happening,
we're up there.
We're still enjoying ourselves,
but they're,
you know,
you can't really sit outside.
There's ash raining down and it was threatened.
I mean like it smelled.
You could see that.
Um,
what would be a clear view is actually like this,
remember we were like,
why is it hazy?
Like,
oh that smoke from the fire.
So that shit's happening.
And then we go,
um,
we're hanging out and then we get word that,
oh,
there's a fire in southern California.
Oh,
cool.
What's that?
A year ago there was the big,
the Thomas Fire and a couple of those in the La area.
Remember when like the near the Getty was on fire,
it was on fire.
Yeah.
So now me valley was on fire last year.
That's right.
And those were big fires.
Now this one is like unprecedented the way that it spread and
the perfect conditions for fire,
you know,
because you have a like a,
what is it,
zero.
Yeah.
Zero humidity.
So Super Dry,
big Santa Ana winds,
gusts of up to 65 miles an hour sometimes.
And Yeah,
just very dry conditions and a lot of brush.
Yeah,
just fire everywhere man.
And usually,
I mean those poor people that are in that,
in the Malibu area,
they always get it and it got it again.
But this time it started to spread further south and east,
which threatens where we live as well.
So I'm sure if you follow social media,
you saw rogue and got evacuated.
He lives,
uh,
west of us.
But,
um,
yeah,
so we,
we had to,
you know,
they're telling us we don't have like a,
we're not at the mandatory yet,
but we also,
you know,
we have kids,
we have,
we have dogs and you could see like the smoke has grown,
you smell it outside now
the town
has been since last night,
so we're next on the call sheet.
Yeah.
So it just makes sense.
I think it's the,
it's so smoky and I don't,
I just don't want to get that panic.
Like where they're like,
go,
go.
That's apparently what's happening is by the time they're telling you to leave,
it's like,
yeah,
you don't have the time to collect your druthers.
And I dunno,
I'd tell you it's a,
it's really cry again,
it's very emotional for me to see these fires cause I grew up here and I've seen
Malibu burned down like how many times.
It's an unbelievable,
but to see the valley kind of get it where I just,
I can't,
it's so hard for me to even see it.
Yeah.
I hate it.
It's terrible and scary too because you know,
whatever,
it's scary.
It's very scary.
I know you,
you start seeing,
I mean fire is always scary and you see these big fires and they're showing last
night we're just seeing like all these homes just completely collapse and cars
on fire and they're like,
oh these people died in their car.
It's just horrible stuff.
I know.
And it makes you think like,
well,
you know,
it's,
it's obviously possible that it could come over to our area.
And so we,
uh,
we're close baby.
We're like,
it's,
it's like three streets down dude.
That's not three streets down three major streets.
Yeah.
Literally.
No,
literally and,
and that's another thing I,
cause because I grew up on these mean streets,
I'm like,
oh my God,
there's a fire there.
I know that neighborhood.
That's where my best friend's family is.
And Yeah.
So anyway,
we're getting the fuck out of here.
But we thought,
well there's still time cause we don't know when we can come back to her house.
Yeah.
Just to do this.
And I know in a horrible scenario,
I thought about it too.
It's like this,
a studio could be gone.
Could,
yeah.
Could be highly possible.
And you know,
we're packing the essentials.
We've got our lubricants,
we got Dildos,
dildos.
Uh,
we got the fisting thing of the cuffs.
Flashlights.
Yeah.
Toilet paper.
Like all the real family important stuff.
Well,
I will tell you that when I saw Joe had evacuated,
I was like,
Oh shit.
Like we were still in Napa Valley and he was with marshal at a studio.
And I'm like,
Oh wow,
okay.
Cause he's our,
he's,
yeah.
Further west.
And I'm like,
that means that Jesus Christ that's coming our direction.
Um,
it's very scary.
And that,
and so by the time we landed,
we saw the fires from the airplane that we were in and it was just chaos.
It's chaos.
And I think what scares me the most is that it's not contained at all.
It's a zero,
not like 10% containment.
And usually the fire department,
they draw a line and,
and the fire doesn't cross that line.
But because there's no line right now,
that's the part that I'm like,
time to go.
The other thing and people no containment,
don't know about.
Um,
so today,
like overnight Friday going into Saturday,
the winds died.
The winds are the worst thing for the fire.
This is why it's a catastrophe and it starts a new,
so it died,
the winds died and they got like some work done and put out some,
you know,
very little containment.
Then they're like,
oh,
going into Sunday we're going to get Santa Ana's again,
going to pick up and who knows what'll happen.
Well and the Santa Ana's are going to blow it directly towards us.
That's the real kicker.
And what's really mortifying is that there's not enough help because of the
northern California fires.
We don't have as many resources down here.
So that's what's happening too,
is like when we were flying in,
I'm like,
where the fuck are the helicopters dumping water?
Not to say that there aren't firefighters giving their lives to,
they are.
They are.
But I'm saying that usually,
I mean,
when Bel Air was on fire,
you,
you saw them just dumping,
dumping dumpy.
I'm like,
well where,
where are these people?
And so they're bringing crews and from Arizona now to help us fight this fire
because it's 0% contained.
You know,
those guys are amazing.
The first response,
my God,
I mean,
look,
I'm not shitting on you guys.
Anybody that's helping us fight the fire.
I'm just saying that it does seem like there's way less out there.
Well,
I think it seems like less because of how enormous this House,
oh my God,
I saw that thing today where they said there's 900 firefighters,
which you know,
I don't know what that sounds like to you.
That doesn't sound like,
yeah,
when you talk about the scope of this thing,
it's really big one in Pepperdine.
All those students that are in there and the quote fireproofed who knows fire
right now is burned a 70,000 acres here.
It's not,
this is going to be higher by the time it comes out.
It is nuts.
I Dunno.
I,
you know,
again,
I've seen a lot of shit go down in this part of La.
I saw the 1994 we had an earthquake that just took down the San Fernando valley,
but I feel like this is on par.
This is another key major disaster upon us.
It's really scary.
We,
um,
anyways,
I was jerking off or
beautiful there in the afternoon.
We did make marital love.
Does any APP,
that's me.
I recorded myself.
Holy War on Ethan and Ilos podcast age three.
And you made it sound like we hadn't done it in,
I was backed up though.
It wasn't,
I backed up.
Yeah,
I remember you gave me a nut check before you were like,
you are backed up.
Well,
a lot of people don't know that.
I,
I can tell exactly when was the last time you're not swear evacuated and they
were evacuated big time on that trip.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Everything came out.
I can touch them and just see that they're full or they're hard.
Why?
They're low and loose.
That's they're low.
I know that they've been milked and they're kind of lower and softer.
Yeah,
they're relaxed.
That's empty.
And if they're a top higher and they're kind of full and heavy,
then odd.
But that's funny that they're heavy in their higher,
I don't know why you're,
that's what you're nuts.
Do you,
you're like kind of a nut expert.
I'm a Tom.
None expert.
I W I wouldn't say I'm an all.
We say you're the ball queen.
And what's her name?
The ball hot.
Uh,
Peyton Lafferty.
Lafferty.
Yeah,
I think it was Peyton.
Hi
Peyton Lafferty.
Oh Huh.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yup.
Paul Sullivan.
That calm.
That didn't even make sense.
I know she said to rub your balls all over that come what she likes.
That is not what she was saying.
She likes.
She likes it.
Nobody likes that.
No.
Yeah.
Rose well does balls all over those tits.
That's tats.
That's hot tap.
Everybody likes that.
T e t.
S
it's fucking hot.
It feels manufacturer.
It feels normal and sexy to me.
Very sexy.
Sexy.
How about this guy on the train though?
We watched him for a minute.
What cities is this?
Um,
I'm saying I'm going with east coast.
Well,
diesels.
Good Shit.
Blood on the Schrader
for train the trains with me.
I'm selling blood,
he's fucked up,
but he's also,
he's,
this is smart advertising.
This is how somebody takes advantage of an opportunity.
You have potential customers all around you.
You have a voice that works.
Might as well announced that if you're looking for weed,
you get on the four train and all summer I'm going to be here selling it.
It's word of mouth.
Yeah.
It's like,
well,
I mean look weed's not that big of a deal anymore to most people,
but you're still sometimes looking like where to get it and if I'm on this train
I'm like,
oh,
I just hop on the four train.
This guy's going to be selling weed.
Well,
I'd say the benefit to his salesman ship is that you're on the train.
Maybe it's a nice time saver to have a two for one.
Absolutely.
Buy Our coffee and then I took the four train five days a week.
I'll just look for this guy.
Yeah.
Where is that?
Where's the drunk guy in the jacket?
Right.
And the two or five jackets and he's wearing,
where's the drug?
Five jacket guy with that loud ass fucking purple Derp will that he was
uploading sour diesel he's wearing wait one,
two,
three,
four jackets like jacket,
check,
check.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's a lot of jackets,
but it's probably to hide all that weed.
Yeah.
Wow.
What the wife died.
Her name was on the least,
not his and that's why I'm homeless.
Oh.
So he's really like,
he's basically saying I'm not.
I'm homeless by circumstance.
It's kind of not really.
Look ladies,
I don't judge hard live with my mom.
Yeah.
I live here on the fourth time capable of monogamy kind of guy who was the
marrying kind.
I also have five jackets.
If you're cold,
you think he'd share his jacket with me?
Absolutely.
[inaudible] he's got to memorize.
That's cool.
That's a lot of time on the train.
Yeah.
That is one thing I do miss living in Los Angeles.
This is like public transit.
That's not the thing here.
It's not,
but it should be because I feel like we have so many crazy people that could
really shine.
People watching.
I know like every time I go to New York,
I just love the subway situation.
So experience that's part is a,
nobody makes eye contact and people like we'll eat on the bus,
the subway,
which is so disgusting to me.
There's always a little threat of danger always.
That's what makes it more exciting.
Yeah.
Well there's always somebody fighting or starting a fight,
but you're not allowed to look,
which is really annoying because if you look then you could get involved.
You know,
you always have this thing where you get to,
people watch and you can go.
Sometimes people give you the signal like it's okay to watch me.
You know what I mean?
They'll,
they'll have a look to them,
but like I know I'm fucking weird and then you could watch me.
They know they know what they're doing and they put it out there like I'm not a
threat.
And then there's people who you think are no threat whatsoever and they fucking,
we'll flex on you and you're like,
oh shit,
don't look at that guy.
I had to go down to the La county clerk last week to pick up our child's birth
certificate.
That kind of office is it's Yo,
that's one where you look at a rar.
Subway,
put it this way.
I got a bag of Takis and a bottle of water before I wanted to stand in line
cause I was like Oh shit it's going to be on.
And Lo and behold it was on some shit cause you got people getting married.
You got people getting death certificates.
Birth certificates was baby daddies.
You know what I'm saying?
I saw like,
you know,
15 year old girls with babies getting the birth certificate.
I saw some real rough look in people.
Yeah,
there's a lot of scary mother goddesses.
Birth and death that United State money that is um,
like an even playing field.
It brings in all kinds.
You know what I was thinking though is like what do super famous people do?
Like I thought that too.
Like you have to go to the DMV if you're a fucking Mariah Carey or whoever or
cost.
Can you send someone?
Well like it's an official document.
I know.
Let's say it goes down because it's in Oklahoma and it was probably like,
he's probably like,
Hey,
I'm g and everyone goes nuts and they probably come out and they're like,
we realize this is an inconvenience for you,
so we already prepped everything for you.
And he's like,
Oh shucks,
did you?
Yeah,
I just like you.
And they're like,
I know you are.
Here's your thing,
just sign here.
I can't imagine.
Yeah,
like famous people Hashtag thank y'all very much.
Like you have to get a death certificate of birds are getting [inaudible].
I felt like this Brad Pitt just fucking show up places and he's like,
Hey,
do I need to sign?
I'm in line.
Brad Pitt has to do with the eye exam at the DMV or get his driver's license
renewals wouldn't.
How do you get around the eye exam?
Love an answer on this.
I know.
So many levels to fame.
Like I remember I did jury duty a few years ago and Adam McKay was behind me and
I was like,
Oh shit.
But he's also like this very progressive,
you know,
I could see him being like,
this is my,
my civic duty.
And he's also,
he's famous,
but he's not famous in the way that like people are going to swarm him.
Well,
I don't know what he looks like.
I knew it was now,
but you know him.
So he's the writer director.
He did everything from anchorman two.
He just did that new,
that new one that's going to come out,
uh,
with about Vice President Cheney
where I showed you the trailer where it's fucking Christian Bale.
God,
it looks amazing.
And he did that one about the,
you know,
the stock market,
the,
what does it,
long story short,
was it called,
you know what I mean?
With uh,
Steve Carrell also had Christian Bale.
It was about like,
uh,
the collapse in Oh eight.
Anyways,
he's a great writer,
director,
but of course,
like he's not somebody who everyone's going to recognize right away.
Um,
but yeah,
I was thinking like,
would deniro be behind me like jury duty today?
I mean,
technically he supposed to,
well,
right.
Yeah.
Like everybody gets called in for that shit and being like,
just doing my duty.
But it doesn't exclude you from being a civilian.
But then again,
Taylor swift showed up to take,
that was on the news.
She went to swift.
Oh yeah.
She,
she went to the dorm all now,
from what I understand also like,
I mean,
jury duty was fucking chaos when she was there,
you know?
Oh,
hold on.
I just got sat an update from,
uh,
Kelly who's about five minutes from us.
There's an updated map,
but disaster map and I don't know,
let's see.
Yeah,
it looks like we're getting into Canoga Park.
Yeah.
Okay.
It is,
yeah.
It's spreading to Canoga.
Yeah,
it's not good.
It's not good.
Yeah.
There's an incident map.
Look,
it's coming towards us now.
It's getting closer to Mulholland Ghibli.
So my friend who lives like five minutes west of us is kind of giving us
updates.
She's closer to the fire than we are.
It's coming around the mountain,
man.
Come on.
[inaudible] earning Ini so I can send it to us.
What a surreal thing,
man.
This fire is,
it's just devastating.
It's so surreal.
I mean,
this is a disaster.
It's pretty wild,
man.
What are we talking about?
Oh,
famous people.
Uh,
yeah.
How the fuck,
okay.
If anybody has any insight on that,
like how do the mega famous people of the world do average people things like
how do they,
how do they get away with it if they're like,
I can't,
like how do they get away with it?
Who Do they tell these two falls to go down?
And especially like,
you know,
with jury duty,
if Taylor swift can go,
you're fucking,
that's right.
You know,
Okay.
She's just sending me a good maps,
boy.
What's it saying?
Ah,
let me see another maps.
You sending out a live fire web app,
so let's see.
A,
it's just a nightmare,
but it is spreading out.
The winds are,
uh,
they're picking up right now.
Well,
it's spreading.
I mean,
that's what,
that's what this is about.
Hold on,
let me see.
Fuck yeah,
it's uh,
coming down the mountain.
Oh,
here's another one.
Gene,
I'll show you.
[inaudible] fucked.
Yeah,
I knew that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hi Eva stokes.
Canyon.
Calabasas Fun,
but that's still the same area.
That is still the same area.
That's the same exit there.
Oh,
okay.
This is the same area.
Yeah.
Shit man.
Chatsworth is getting fucked too.
I felt Roscoe there.
Eva.
No good dude's no goods.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Here's the,
here's the thing.
It is just so sad.
I mean,
look,
we're fortunate that we have a plan where,
note,
we know where we're going to go here in a few hours,
but there are some people that probably don't have,
you know,
family or friends or somewhere to go and
my heart just goes out to them.
So how it was so horrible.
I just thought they can contain it.
It's just not happening though.
I know the f and the winds are going to kick up tomorrow.
It's no good.
I wish this guy,
we're here to sell this weed right now.
Okay.
It would be really helpful actually,
which we could get fucking ripped.
Let's go after this.
We're going to go and we're going to get ripped.
We're going to settle in and get ripped.
That's what it's all about.
Natural disaster situations,
you know.
Getting housed.
Actually,
there was this woman on the news last night.
Um,
it's a very fucked up story.
She and her husband were in Westlake village and they evacuated and they came
back and their house was destroyed and he was like,
you know,
I'm just thankful that we're,
uh,
everything we're okay.
Everything with a heartbeat is okay right now.
And the wife,
her lips were totally purple.
Her teeth were totally purple.
She's like,
yeah,
I grew up in Poland and I flat a lot of stuff,
just that house.
She's like,
it's okay.
I'm like,
you poor woman.
You know,
she just started drinking.
The minute she felt safe.
I'm like,
girl,
I'm a dude.
I shit tonight.
You're going to see my ass drunk tonight.
I'll be there too.
I'll be,
oh my shit.
Can I have my coffee back?
Please kind of stole that.
[inaudible]
he's single.
Yeah.
How many thought he was gay?
He said he was,
nobody thought he was gay.
No,
I thought it was good.
He said he was married to a,
was just making sure that his single announcement was received by the,
I don't know why he's so threatened by all these gay men.
Hmm.
Like fish
ass bitch
does she,
she's not amused right over here.
No,
she is a music.
She's a holding it.
So yeah,
she likes to Shit's funny as fuck.
I don't know.
Get a dish do you think?
I don't think she's,
she's holding,
she's like,
she's like damn.
She was like,
I prefer cleaner comedy.
Your dish.
Oh man,
that shit is fucking good.
Pray
every Sunday night.
That true.
That's not true.
No,
it's not about that party is lying.
The other stuff he might be telling the truth about,
I think he's selling weed on the four train.
I think his wife died.
Um,
I think he wants you to wash your ass.
I don't think he wants you to have a sneaky box,
but I don't think he has three sons every Saturday.
Run for president.
Could be.
It's got a lot of good points.
He does have a lot of good point.
Ooh.
Remember when you are a kid though and you see like a crazy drunk guy,
it really fucks with you.
If you see a guy like that.
I remember vividly we were visiting Chicago and we went to church because we
always had to go to church and we're leaving church and this is like in the city
and somewhere downtown Chicago we're leaving and there was a crazy lady on the
corner and I'm a young,
I mean I'm nine or 10 and she goes,
had Darya had dare you,
drank his fucking blood.
And I was like,
whoa.
I was just like holding on to my dad and I was like,
Oh shit.
Because I didn't have a concept of that's a mentally sick or highly inebriated.
You don't know what that is.
You just know that that woman said some crazy.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
why?
She's saying that?
And he was so calm.
He was like,
oh,
she's a,
she's not,
she's not doing well.
It's not like,
I don't remember exactly.
I remember he put me at ease.
I mean he didn't really explain it to me.
Of course parents really like explain this to the mentally sick.
He was just like,
don't listen to her.
She's a,
doesn't know what she's saying.
It's that kind of thing.
Just dismissive of it.
And I was like,
but why is she saying that?
Cause she was saying such crazy stuff,
you know,
and she's yelling at people leaving the church.
And I was like yelling at us.
I remember my mother and I,
when we lived in this horrible,
it's like scary apartment complex.
I say scary because
there was a drunk woman that lived drunk is scary to children.
And One night it was our bedroom windows and there was like a little alley and
then the other apartment complex.
So this woman would get hammered and then drop shit into her toilet.
And I remember,
she's like,
yeah,
ah,
eh.
Just out of her mind.
And My mother in the middle of the night drags me with her to confront,
this is so stupid drunk woman.
And she goes,
I dragged my,
rang him up soil latch.
I can't get it out.
Like she was so hammered.
And I remember as a little girl being terrified that we'd confronted this crazy
person.
What'd your mom say to her?
She's like,
you should shut the fuck up because you,
you're scanning my daughter.
You're scaring us.
Close your window.
Because she left her window open and that's why it was summertime.
So our window is up because my mother would never pay for air conditioning and
her window was open and everybody could hear her.
She said she told her,
shut up everyone.
Fuck everyone who doesn't run a C and opens windows.
That's money well spent dude.
And it's dangerous to keep your window open at night in a big city in the
summertime.
It's a stupid every fat guy listening,
nodding right now.
Fuck them.
My parents were both super cheap,
so no heat in the winter during our nighttime sleeping and then no cool.
Remember to this irrational fixation with numbers.
Like we would run the AC,
but I remember my dad would be like,
put it to 73 and be like,
wait,
that's not cool enough.
It's feels good to me.
And he'd be like,
it's a good temperature.
You know,
if you went below that,
he'd be like,
why are you adjusting it?
It's fucking hot outside.
Let it be cool in here.
Such like,
uh,
what's gotta be that number?
No,
it's gotta be cool.
See,
I disagree with your cooling theory and your cooling philosophy has garbage.
Here's why.
What ends up happening is because people like you,
it's the same people that overcompensate for the heater indoors in the winter
time.
If you over cool the house in the summer,
then it's too cold.
Now I have to go put on a sweater.
No such thing.
It's like being wintertime and those such things.
There's no such thing as too cool in the,
in the dead of summer.
It makes me feel sick.
I have to sleep under the down comforter when defends 105 outside.
I want it to feel like a meat locker and said,
I want my house to feel 74 all the time.
I got to,
I got to meet somebody else.
I can't do this.
That's the deal breaker.
It really,
it's up there.
It's at the top of the list.
I actually 75 feels perlick effect.
I'm going to start playing more vomit clip.
We'll stop,
stop saying nonsense.
Then even in the,
even in the dead of summer,
I like it.
I don't like it so cold cause like then it's,
then you're all fucked up.
It's all hot and then you come in and it's,
it doesn't feel good.
All right.
I can't stand you,
but listen,
it's like you're sick.
I can't stand you.
I'm just,
so when I was in,
uh,
Florida a few weeks ago,
sometimes it happens.
That shows where you finish a show and as you're saying a thank you,
good night to the audience,
someone in the front row,
we'll try to hand you something.
Yeah.
You know,
so and you know,
usually are like,
what is,
cause it's kind of a crazy rush of them happening.
Like you're saying goodbye.
People are applauding your walking offstage and was like,
let me give this to you.
And a lot of times it'll be,
I dunno,
sometimes it's something someone drew.
Uh,
sometimes it's like food or something.
You know,
sometimes you look at somebody like,
I can't,
what am I supposed to do with this?
It's just shit that's,
you know,
it's hard to say whether it's something you want.
Right.
Um,
anyways,
the other day that show ended and this guy has something and I'm like,
okay.
And I reached forward.
This guy handed me a DVD copy of riding the bus with my sister.
Oh yeah.
That is that movie that he got so excited about.
Um,
the one we are packing for our escape here.
Yeah.
And you were like,
I have to take this and you brought the deer.
Like you don't have to take that.
And I was like,
it's pretty important.
Um,
it does feel if I'm being honest,
it does feel pretty,
pretty important.
Um,
that's,
can we watch it?
We don't have a DVD player.
Dewey,
I don't know the hotel might do that would make life so worth living as it not
on iTunes.
This ridiculous.
Phil,
let's see.
That's in the fourth seven one drops.
I said not here.
I hear Rosie O'donnell playing a slow adult.
Yeah.
What year is this?
Shit,
man.
I think this came in.
Oh,
it was a while ago for sure.
And DVD.
Yeah,
it's 2005.
Um,
anyway,
somebody,
Joe is beautiful and successful.
Lovely as a stall or river.
Excellent.
They have nothing in common.
Didn't know you had a sister.
She's retarded.
That's so,
that's the movie.
Anyways.
You want to try to watch it over the weekend?
Of course.
It's all I've ever wanted.
I'm pretty excited about it.
But then I got pointed to this other mug.
We were talking about this.
Everyone started sending me clips of this movie.
They're like,
have you seen it?
Miss
Carolyn Steven's life together?
It was perfect.
I've got to get going right the second.
Hey Baby.
Hey,
there's one small problem.
Uh,
I'm wrong.
I'm his brother.
We're twins.
So this is Matthew mcconaughey and what's that actor's name there?
That was such a famous actor.
This was Gary Oldman.
Yeah,
Gary Oldman.
Are you kidding me?
And your parents?
It can tear them apart.
I think you've got to let me know that everyone in your pants is images,
images,
Carolyn doors.
Bring them together.
Are you
welcome?
I'm Steven.
There you are.
This is Steven's father Bruno and his mom Kathleen and over behind the bar
students,
brother.
He could have prepared us for this study.
I think bass me,
I'll never speak to cancer.
Just get it together.
It doesn't,
it looks completely made up.
This looks like a parody.
Yeah,
this is Gary Oldman.
Gary Oldman.
Matthew mcconaughey.
Kate was in that.
Kate Beckinsale is this ridiculously a list?
Cats,
right?
And then they're all Matthew mcconaughey.
When did this come out?
And this is a joke.
When the going gets rough,
it's only the size of your heart.
That sounds his voiceover,
this great gal.
And you didn't tell her that her baby's probably gonna be lit.
I'm not like you will also cute and cuddly discriminate against us.
Guy From game of Thrones.
Dinklage yeah,
this thing looks insane.
How did this get,
this is crazy.
Why can't I get more movies made?
This is,
I don't know.
But when did this come out man?
I mean this is blowing my mind right now.
That came out in 2003 that's why it got buried.
But the thing is to get the,
okay,
so here's the trivia.
Can't even direct your Matthew Bright was fired after he turned in this cut and
the whole film was in re edited.
Peter Dinklage has said the original director's cut,
which screened in Austin was gorgeous.
But the people who fired him ruin the movie.
So who knows?
Um,
it looks really nutso.
God,
I want to see it so,
so stupid.
I know.
It's like this
just a walked down the aisle in this,
the craziest voice over and just helps me
is just a beginning.
Sounds like a student film voiceover.
The copy does it.
I'm still reeling from the need to show her,
giving him a blow job.
Oh,
and the first perfect relationship.
And she's blowing him.
Yeah.
Like that's the,
okay.
He's like careful.
I got magic come in there and then they cut to the next thing.
Is that what I missed that?
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
And they have a baby
and now to some Langley productions,
probably present command performances.
Kate Beckinsale,
Matthew mcconahey,
Patricia Arquette achieve a lifetime gather all in my lifetime.
That's one way of saying
tiptoes.
Joke.
Yeah.
It's really crazy.
Yeah,
of course.
Now,
what would happen?
I mean,
this movie would never come out.
It's really crazy,
man.
But that voiceover guy,
you're not fixated on it.
I cannot get over that.
Horrible.
It's horrible.
It's notably bad.
Yeah.
And it's like the copy all bed and his,
they got like the cheap voiceover guy.
It's all bad.
Why didn't you hire the real voiceover guy?
You know,
world.
Yeah.
I know.
Tip toes tip toes in that role of a lifetime.
The role of a lifetime.
Gary Old Gary Old,
he said,
Matthew mcconahey,
he said it wrong.
I've never heard it said
that's what you want.
I met Matthew Mcconaughey,
right?
No,
I was at a party.
Yeah.
So I used to hang out with this,
do,
I took an acting class like 2003 the one of the guys in my class was a tennis
instructor to a very wealthy lady whose husband divorced her.
No,
he,
she lived across the street from Matthew Mcconaughey and directly next to her
lived at an arms dealer,
like a Saudi arms dealer who had bulletproof cars and shit.
And One night I went over,
I was hanging out,
we go,
he's like,
oh,
the neighbors having a party,
the Nate though the arms guys like I dunno,
close to 60.
And everyone at this parties in their twenties.
Right.
And then I see someone on his basketball court,
uh,
wearing swim trunks and nothing else.
I'm like,
who the fuck is that?
Matthew mcconaughey.
And then he comes over and like the girls are like,
oh my God,
it's about the Bakala Ohio.
And the girl goes,
how do you spell that?
And he goes,
that's a good question.
Then then he spelled icon,
hey,
and then she goes,
can you say it again?
And he was like,
yeah.
And he spelled his last name again.
And then I realized,
because he has this great lush hair,
he had goggles,
swim goggles on,
and then he put them on and then he was like,
I already spelled it twice for you
somehow.
And this is like early two thousands.
That was in the,
uh,
you know,
like us weekly.
There was pictures of that party.
The goggles?
No,
just him being at this party.
Why was he wearing goggles when he was playing?
Because he was wearing swimming trunks,
so he's probably swimming at his house and then he came over and he was losing
his piece of flair.
Like,
you know how mystery was flair mysteries to tell guys if they want to eat,
you need to have like an odd item on you.
The girls will ask about.
Yeah,
yeah.
I thought maybe that's what that was.
Yeah.
Interesting.
It's very,
very odd.
Very odd experience.
I was like,
oh,
that's Matthew mcconaughey.
He's just like us.
Just like us.
Celebrities are just like,
yeah,
just like us.
He's plays basketball and his shorts with swimming goggles on.
Just like us.
Yup.
Oh,
fucking Miami tippy toes.
Tip Toes,
tip toes.
I have a midget baby.
She gets knocked up and then that's terrible.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
he doesn't tell her that he has that DNA.
Then you tip toes.
I mean,
just give somebody a heads up so that they can decide.
You should probably let them know.
Just Carolyn doors.
That's a good point.
Hey,
but she was blowing him all the time.
You think that she didn't get nuts busted in her?
That was the implication.
And it's top of movie.
That's true.
She's sucking his wiener all day long.
That's really good point.
Really cool way of putting that.
It's just like the gays.
Okay.
They do to,
you know,
like get is um,
gene,
would you like to try a,
would you rather?
Yeah,
I think this is a,
yeah,
this came in here from our listeners.
Hi,
Mommy's love you both love the podcast after a major decadent dinner binge
followed by some dental care.
I thought of this.
Would you rather,
would you rather never be able to floss again?
Ooh,
no,
but only half of the calories of every food you eat counted
or floss with abandoned.
Never have another dental update issue again.
But all of the foods you eat count as one and a half times their co.
Fuck.
Oh my God.
First one,
former fatty with great teeth.
Arianna first one.
I know,
right?
I would just be too fat.
That'd be such,
I mean I feel like my body already processes calories as double what they're
worth.
So you give me this thing,
I'm fucking 400 pounds by the fall.
I mean by,
by the new year.
I know.
So yeah,
I can't do it.
However,
when we were in Napa Valley,
I,
we,
I had eaten meat and then afterwards I was panicked because I didn't think there
was dental floss.
Yeah.
So I was like pulling strings out of my shirt and flossing and shit.
It was terrible.
I don't like that feeling of meat stuck in my team.
I have so much,
I mean,
it's always a struggle and I think it will always be a struggle.
But if so much awareness about food and exercise now,
especially in the last couple of years,
and I realized how weak and vulnerable I can be to this,
especially because we,
uh,
we had a driver who picked us up who had a box of pastries.
He was like,
oh,
I got these this morning.
And he handed it to us when we were on our way and I opened that thing and I was
like,
it was like fresh croissants and just pastries.
I started to devour these things.
Oh yeah.
It was just mid morning and we got to our hotel and I was like,
I feel sick.
And you're like,
oh,
what's wrong?
I'm like,
I don't know.
I think I just ate too many pastries right now cause I couldn't control myself.
Yeah,
I really,
I was like,
yeah.
If somebody is just like,
Oh,
do you want these delicious treats?
I'm like,
okay.
I don't do the normal thing of like I'll have one or no,
I'm good.
I already ate.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
You do like sweets.
That's your jam right there.
I like all food.
That's true.
People always like,
do you like sweets?
I'm like,
not any more than I like other foods.
I like food.
I like to eat.
It's a such a struggle.
Um,
what's this here?
Here's another one.
Hey,
John and Christine.
She's just my boyfriend and I listened to your old.
What'd you rather as we have a quick new one for the mommies.
Okay.
Would you rather go pee?
Would you rather go pee pee in your pants every time you do a standup show?
Fuck.
I pretty much do.
Or Shit,
your pants.
Every time you do a podcast,
I must remain in the said soiled items of clothing for the duration of either
the standup show or the podcast.
You've got to be out of your fucking mind.
This is an easy one.
You can't make it this easy.
Of course,
I'm going to stay in there and my piss.
I'm not gonna sit here in my shit pants and do podcasts.
I pretty much pee every time.
I laugh.
Every time I laugh and my Pants,
I've got pee pants,
pee panties,
and I where you pee on?
Like any exertion of saying something,
but I left my kid up.
I piss,
I laugh,
I pass.
I'm really used to it by now.
Yeah.
It's not that it's not that severe.
I mean it would suck to do every show.
You're like,
all right,
I gotta do my show now.
And you pissed and you stay there.
I do stand there and soaked pallets,
so,
but that's,
there's pee in my panties.
That's what this is saying.
Like soaked,
soaked.
Would you rather sit and soaked pants,
standing soaked pants or sit and shit pants?
No one wants to sit in shit pants and sit here for a whole podcast,
choose PP people.
It was just so nasty,
so fucking nasty.
Here's a cool guy.
If you don't know this guy,
um,
there's this cool dad right here,
okay.
Dressed up as a a Nazi and dressed his son up as Hitler.
And he's like,
what does everyone,
uh,
I'm a history buff.
Cause that's what you think of when you see people in here.
You're like,
this guy fucking loves history.
You Watch that,
uh,
you watching the history channel thing.
And he's like,
yeah,
how'd you know?
I'm like,
well,
you're wearing that Nazi gear.
And he's like,
I just finished it,
man.
It's a great series.
Yeah.
World War Two man.
Wild stuff.
I'm trying to think of another costume that's inherently such a bad idea.
Like is there another figure in our history that's equally as I charged?
I mean,
I think it goes,
look,
I'm not a,
I'm not a social justice warrior by any stretch,
but even I know
that like,
that's just kind of a,
no,
no.
And I'm not,
I'm not pushing for that guys.
Right.
To do that.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like you don't go,
you just don't.
You don't go a Stalin,
you don't go Hitler,
but what's even more amazing is how brash it is to get upset that people were
upset about it.
I mean,
this guy
wore this to a Halloween event and he got upset with people who got upset with
him.
He wore an s s outfit dress.
His five year old son is Hitler,
put them in a fake mustache,
swats it.
Photo was taken.
He was at an Owensboro annual event,
which kids trick or treat?
Oh my God.
The costume understandably offended many people and afterwards he shared his
indignation in a Facebook post.
Yeah.
Anyone who knows us knows we love history and we often dress as historical
figures.
Okay.
Tonight as we walked,
we saw people dressed as murderers,
devil's serial killers of blood and Gore.
Nobody batted an eye,
but me,
I mean,
my little guy,
we dressed as these historical figures and all kinds of people were making snide
remarks and approaching us and threatening my little five year old boy who was
just dressed as Hitler.
I don't get it.
What's going on with people right now?
You're saying that I'm out of line.
Jeez,
guy had an accident.
Head blood falling out of his head.
Nobody said anything.
I guess.
You know what would be the equivalent?
You guys are crazy.
You know it'd be the equivalent is somebody dressed as Osama bin Ladin maybe.
Right?
Cause that's such another hated historical figure like you,
you know what?
That person did dip shit.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's just not very intelligent.
You think it's not intelligent?
I don't know,
but I'm trying to,
I mean,
look,
I,
I'm all for freedom of expression,
but you just know that's a stupid one.
It seems.
It seems like a lot,
like what's the victory?
You know what I mean?
Like you're fighting to do that.
All right.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I don't know this guy.
That's your thing.
You have to dress like Hitler.
I'm different.
I approved juice,
so I'm not like that guy.
You have to do that.
I mean,
I like him.
this is like a coincidence.
I like history and then it so happened I was dressed as a history guy and then
you guys get,
maybe you need to read more history.
That's,
that's kid's defense,
I guess.
You don't like history at all.
It's so bizarre.
You know?
Ah,
the world is upside down.
It's something,
I think you've always been like this by the way.
One,
I'm glad somebody sent this in that it's,
you get uncomfortable watching old people be flirty or sexy.
Yeah,
it's disgusting.
And this guy,
I think he's recording his dad flirting on the phone.
Oh No,
I love it.
Love it.
That's the guy's dad.
Tell me fuck off.
And sometimes
they give me a little warning
today I was going to take advantage of you.
Oh boy.
Hey you go try and give me [inaudible].
That's like someone's dad talking in front of them too.
Right?
That's weird.
So nasty.
Legit talking in front of your kid like you got me all warmed up right now.
Yeah.
Give me a feel and all kinds of ways of getting horny.
So nasty.
Huh?
Go tell him my damn mom on you.
Try to take advantage of me.
I get my drug.
Yeah,
I'd be a damn shame when you were on it.
Where's you're going to make me feel good?
Uh Huh.
Huh?
Oh,
okay.
God,
if you're trying to get Dan to calm down
the street and at the end of condoms to kind of back.
Oh boy.
You know,
that's just a disgusting is hearing your parents tell you dirty jokes.
It's a lot.
Yeah.
That's a form of like child abuse.
When you tell it like you,
when you're sex overtly sexual in front of your children,
it's abuse.
It's disgusting.
It's,
it's,
yeah.
I had a friend whose mother would always tell dirty jokes to him like sexual
jokes and it's totally messed him up.
I don't think it's good.
Could you imagine your mother being Luth Tomi Tomi photo makes me so
your father has a huge cook.
Oh,
and he make me so horny.
Yeah.
I do have big balls,
but he does.
I've seen them,
but he didn't show them to me.
I just happened to see them.
What,
how slips around on the bed?
No,
he was,
he was in his room.
I walked in unannounced and he had already showered and he was putting on
underwear.
I saw him bend down.
Oh my God.
And I saw these big pig nuts from behind.
He does have five PSI now.
We've talked about this before.
I've seen his nuts.
They're not good.
They're enormous.
But you're not.
You're going to be that big two that you think.
Oh,
they're not already.
That's what I got to start making fetish videos.
I think when your cash and the 70s and the way you like old hanky nuts,
then I'll have like my special clips and big farts.
I got nuts and,
and it'll just be all have like 50 male fans all over the world.
Who was like 50 far on your balls for us,
Tom.
I'll be like,
pay pal me
20 bucks.
I'm not going to far for nothing.
All right.
I make my special videos.
Yeah.
As hasn't come through yet.
I'm not far until I get the money.
How much would you demand for stuff like that?
Yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I got it.
I got to study the market,
but I got to study the market per fart.
$50 a fart.
Yeah,
but I want multiple people paying for them.
yeah,
yeah.
That's pretty good money.
You got that hundred dollar farts,
man.
If people were sending you 100 bucks per farm,
multiple people.
I know.
It's a good business model.
Yeah.
Retire from comedy years ago.
I fart on my balls all the time.
They foreign on my balls.
That'd be my video.
I tucked my balls between my legs right near my asshole and I know what,
check this out.
I fart on my balls.
People are like,
oh my God,
your videos get me so hot.
Men are so nasty.
There me guys out there like this.
The hardest fucking thing around.
So nasty.
Yeah.
Why are you so nasty?
Ties are super nasty.
Oh,
I don't want to know all the way out.
Oh
boy.
You bake button.
Damn toes curl.
My Dad was so inappropriate like he used to have,
um,
I tell you that he'd have a beer that you would scratch off and you can see
ladies,
Ted's uh Huh.
So He'd be like,
go get him a beer.
I've quit.
I was always getting my dad to beer.
Yeah.
And then he would scratch scratchers and see the tits on how many times you get
a beer you think?
Every night as my job really.
Of course you get him the reflux that was an alcoholic.
That's all you do is you learn how to open beer when you're young and bring
drinks when you're young.
That's what alcoholic children brush one all the time.
Oh of course.
That's the only time he paid attention to me is when I was braking
or we be watching the game together and I'd be like,
can I have some of your beer?
And that was like big deal and really pay attention to me then.
And then he'd give me some,
a little bit of beer in a and a cop and dilute it and let me drink some with him
and I felt really special then.
That is kind of Nice.
How old were you?
Seven.
Eight,
nine 10 sure,
sure.
And then he had a Rubik's cube under uh,
there was like a naked lady Rubik's cube.
It's like there,
you know you do Rubik's has different naked ladies on every site.
And that was just out in the house too.
So that was kind of cool as a little girl to see that stuff growing up.
What'd you think of it?
Like,
hmm.
Right.
Really?
This is cool.
Well,
the confusing part because you're stoked because it's a Rubik's cube and you're
a little kid and you're like,
oh sweet,
we've got one of these.
Wait a minute,
there's tits on,
wait a minute.
This is something new.
So that's kind of the thing.
You're one hand excited and then the other hand,
like not,
it feels weird.
There's those people that can do a Rubik's cube in like 30 seconds.
Yeah.
What do you think,
what's going on there?
Back in the 80s there a lot of people that could do that.
I mean,
I'm talking about now,
do you see people in video?
They're like,
oh,
check this out.
But I don't know.
That's such a gift.
Yeah.
How do you see that?
How do you do it?
Such a talent.
Something tells me they might not be the best that conversation,
but it's probably mild Asperger's.
How'd he do it?
And they're like,
wow.
Yeah,
you don't see it.
You're like,
oh,
that was great.
Thanks.
This rock back and forth.
Of course that's who can do that shit.
I wonder if this guy can do it.
So I've been having,
I had this video for a while,
but I didn't know.
I figured you would like this guy.
So I saved it for a minute.
Okay.
And then,
I don't know.
Hello everyone.
Welcome back to another video.
Dimensionalist I'm a dimensionalist today I am going to recite the Lord's prayer
and Aisha Air Mac and the best way I can.
Okay.
I don't even know what happened there.
Oh,
I'm sorry,
I got to 100% but it's likes people pronounce an English word and you know that
what they,
how they hear it and you know,
hey,
that's right.
Or that's almost everybody.
You understand that as,
that's the word.
But it Kinda got it all,
but it's,
it's right kind of
look like one of your friends a little bit.
He's like,
he reminds me,
one of your friends know.
So here it goes.
I don't like this at all.
Excuse me.
I really got ready for getting it ready for us.
Cause hard,
very hard to pronounce.
And he's a syllabus is Aramaic words.
Okay.
Um,
handlebars.
Shamar Knox College.
Shamar Dae Dae Malta.
Is that for I need new teeth.
I don't know the whole thing.
It kind of makes me squirm.
What is it about flow?
Okay,
I'll tell you what's it's on him.
It's too cold.
It's good submission is what you're saying.
It is very close.
Uh,
he is wearing a shirt,
which is a little depressing.
The framings wrong.
I like the background.
I'm seeing an old fridge and seeing a lot of plastic and miscellaneous drugs,
but I end something.
Something's wrong,
you know,
so there's a balance there.
Something's naturally wrong,
but it's not exacerbated by drugs.
So that's a little bit of a,
okay.
Uh,
the lighting's terrible.
The audio is good,
decent,
decent.
I'm upset about that.
And there is some white noise in the ballet or something like that for his
video.
This is a video he's hoping we'd be viewed,
I'm sure by a lot of people who wanted to see him speak Aramaic.
Luckily for him,
we got ahold of it and now people are seeing it.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm also really liking the camera angles on his skin condition and his teeth
condition.
Like it's very good.
Well,
it's neat to see it all very close because you don't want to be like,
what's wrong with his teeth?
Oh,
I see what's wrong.
thank you for showing his skin.
This is what,
very close,
almost microscopic view of what's wrong.
This is what a dermatologist would be saying.
Sure.
The thing is we all have flaws.
Yes.
But you don't want to close up.
You want to hide them.
You want to conceal,
you want to trigger the light.
Yeah.
Hold the camera on the other side of your face.
Okay.
But you're right.
It does have all the makings.
It is a quality submission.
A lot of shit in the background,
the poor lighting,
a lot of stuff.
Not,
not lacking in stuff.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I love it.
Ways Don Canam,
Bosh,
Maya Maha.
Hello.
Kind of Dashaun High Bay.
[inaudible] there's gotta be a linguistic expert who I would please love your,
uh,
your review of his Aramaic could because that,
especially that exchange sounded like I can make up anything and nobody will
know that this is not Aramaic.
Well,
this is a phenomenon.
No,
no way.
But when you're learning air magnet like
La,
la,
hey,
Aramaic,
this head tilt back the moment is my favorite.
Ah,
hello.
Oh Wow.
You know,
I'm just practicing my air arithmetic.
How do you say that there man?
Look at those.
Wow.
Hello?
Let me those Goblin teeth mean.
Yeah,
it's not good.
It's not good.
Not Good.
Not Good Mecca.
Mecca.
Isn't this what hillbillies do when they speak in tongues?
Different how Shababa hello,
hello.
[inaudible] is nonsense.
So it really dumb people do.
I try to tell you that they're really feeling it when that happens.
You know,
JC is tapping.
I'm like,
Hey,
I got to tell you something.
Sure.
Yeah,
but that's what this is,
right?
The speaking in tongues to me.
Sounds similar.
Sounds like some bullshit.
Hotshot.
Hot.
Hot,
hard,
hard.
And there's one out here.
We got to finishing one here.
A last signing bay shuck look towards,
well how large Shalom [inaudible] hello.
Hello.
I mean,
okay.
It's hard on the eye.
Uh,
good job man.
What are you going,
I would love to somebody's school does on and they were like,
that was perfect.
Jeremy,
what's all that mountain of bullshit behind him now that I'm looking?
Uh,
I think Dr drew would say,
well,
there's a little bit a hoarding.
Um,
definitely isn't that what camped?
There might be some mental illness,
drugs or mental illness.
Let's see.
What's your money on?
Uh,
I think,
yeah,
mental.
Yeah.
I'm going to go mental illness on this one too.
Definitely doesn't have the manic presentation of drugs.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh no man.
Grilled chicken coming.
Yeah.
I like chicken.
I know you like chicken.
I want some chicken right now.
You
are so nasty.
Can you are just the nastiest?
Why don't I don't I have my chicken.
I get low wire.
Why fuck you both of you?
I missed her.
I know.
She's so great.
Both of you.
Yup.
I can't wait to become like her shit.
What does that menopause,
that's like 10 years for me.
It's going to be great.
Cut that hair short.
Really shut it down and I can't wait
it out.
Get that real short haircut,
right?
Much more.
Yeah,
like mine.
Mine's a good look for a woman for sure.
That's what they do.
That's funny.
To have this haircut as a woman,
you either have to be gorgeous.
Yeah.
Or not give a fuck.
Right.
One of the two.
You either so beautiful that this haircut actually just people just see your
face and be like,
wow,
she can pull off anything.
Definitely.
Or you're like,
it's repellent.
You Go,
I did this to people.
I mean,
either you're like a model.
You're in your 20s you could just wear a burlap sack and shave your head and
you're beautiful.
But no,
no dude.
Yeah.
Most of you.
Nah,
Nah.
Shit.
Pieces of shit.
Both pieces of shit
like her style,
man.
You know what?
The thing that fucking sucks about an evacuation we're about to do is just the
logistics of it.
The packing up things.
That's the part that actually is the most annoying.
Right?
You're like,
fuck,
I got to get everything together.
That part sucks.
We've already done that part though.
I know,
but that's what I'm saying.
It's like it's the
transporting thing.
Look,
it's all,
it's all bad,
but here's the,
I would rather,
you know,
do it at a leisurely pace and do it at a panicked rate when it's,
when we're going to have to that.
Yeah.
And you know that's imminent.
So let's just do it now.
Settle in so we're not panicked when the call come and then this,
I figured it would be a,
somebody sent this,
this would be of interest to you.
Hey Tad and Katrina,
I thought you guys would appreciate this nugget of space.
Brown knowledge I found had I guess in a museum of some kind in Columbus,
Ohio and joy.
I'm not too dumb to come.
Lindsay
does the crew p it says,
oh yeah,
the space station bathroom has a long plastic tube for collecting urine and a
water free toilet for bowel movements.
I vacuum pulls waste into a special compartment,
foot straps at the base of the toilet.
Help keep the crew members from floating away while they're using the bathroom.
Well,
now this makes sense.
Yeah,
you finally got it.
Oh,
hey fucking
Gosling.
Why couldn't this be in the movie?
Yeah.
Where's that scene?
I notice though,
there's nothing.
Nothing
here about coming.
Yeah,
that's a real disappointed they ejaculate.
Yeah.
Where's that one?
I want to know what they do when they finish,
you know,
shooting their load.
Where does that go?
You know?
Oh,
oh,
she's really into this club today.
That's how you orgasm.
You're really into that one.
[inaudible] Canada high.
Well,
no,
that's a guy just finishing off.
He's jacking his dick in space and then right as he's about to the lotuses load,
he's like,
whoa.
Oh,
it's fun.
It's fun.
Clip.
All right,
so it's an unusual week for us.
Um,
we didn't actually know if we would be able to record anything,
uh,
after this thing started because again,
our studios in our house,
um,
we're going to be leaving.
I don't know if we're coming back Monday,
Tuesday,
late or I don't know what's happening.
I know.
It's,
I mean,
who knows?
Dude,
it's
crazy day for us.
Crazy.
So,
well,
I'm glad we got to take a little break and get into silliness before we go into
this nonsense we're about to embark upon right now.
You very much,
uh,
I know we have a lot of fans and supporters and um,
we appreciate all your guys nice messages of course.
Um,
if you are in,
um,
you know,
a position to help people out,
luckily we don't need your help,
but there's a lot of people out here that do,
so look for those.
Maybe we can post some,
uh,
places that are accepting donations for people in need.
Yeah.
Especially out here in like thousand oaks area.
They went through a lot.
They got fucked.
Um,
so I'll try to find that and post that,
look on our social media,
Twitter and Instagram.
And,
um,
that's that man.
We,
uh,
we'll,
oh,
I fuck,
it's weird to say,
but they posted it.
They put it up.
So I'll just tell you,
we have,
um,
our holiday stuff or holiday merge went out,
or is coming out this coming week.
So it's a,
it's like there's a bunch of,
you know,
there's ornaments,
there's a stocking this year.
The,
uh,
the sweater last year was Santa wears jeans.
This is what you guys here.
It's a Jesus wore jeans and there's also a,
Jesus wore jeans t shirt.
Um,
last year we donated a portion of our proceeds to children's Hospital of Los
Angeles.
This year we're donating to,
uh,
the starlight foundation.
And that is an organization that tries to make hospital stays,
uh,
easier,
more comfortable for kids.
So kids that are in hospitals,
it's sucks enough.
They do things like they'll instead of like,
you know,
hospital gowns are all shitty and rough.
They'll do things like,
uh,
get hospital gowns that have like team logos or,
you know,
kids favorite,
um,
cartoon characters.
And the new thing they're going for now is a virtual reality.
Um,
uh,
for kids in hospitals.
So hopefully what we're gonna do is,
uh,
we'll take a portion of our proceeds from our holiday merge and I hope we're in
a position where we can buy a few virtual reality goggles.
So,
and I'll document that.
I documented a,
a shopping trip last year to toys r us,
which amazingly I think the next month toysrus went out of business.
Can you believe it doesn't exist?
I know it was crazy.
I was like,
I was just there and we bought like carts of toys when we dropped it off at the
donation site.
But um,
I'll do something like that this year where I'll document it.
I like documenting at showing you what we're doing.
So we'll do that again this year.
Uh,
again,
this is a weird week for us,
man.
But,
uh,
hopefully we'll be back,
um,
in another week and we'll have a something to talk about and we'll be in a much
lighter and fun,
more fun mood.
But until then,
um,
we're going to leave you,
I don't even have,
where's my,
I got,
I kind of play a song.
I don't have my songs and I have a song.
Let's see what I got here.
Okay,
I got something.
All right.
Um,
love you guys and we'll see you soon.
Bye.
[inaudible].